bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire pour un best-of un peu
particulier de cette troisième saison
en effet je demande régulièrement mes
invités ce qui caractérise notre époque
et c'est toujours en images qu'il me
réponde
eh bien ce sont leurs réponses celle de
cette année que vous allez voir
maintenant voici donc la solitude en
image un peu sérieuse du style de ce
début de xxième siècle
[Musique]
j'ai cru reconnaître qu'elle effectue
rck et c'est lui c'est un tableau de
bedri baykam c'est ce pacte qui a été
poignardé par des islamistes en 2011
et ça envoie un petit parce qu'on vient
d'entendre les commentaires précédents a
eu un 21ème siècle qui est on a vu
s'affronter les idéologies terrible
fascisme et le bolchévisme et c'est
l'impérialisme américain qui est sorti
vainqueur
on aimerait que ça se répète pas voilà
on aimerait que l'esprit de la
république l'esprit du siècle des
lumières l'esprit des présocratiques
ressurgissent
et puis aussi parce que c'est
d'actualité quand même il y avait cette
phrase célèbre de kemal atatürk il dit
tout mon espoir réside dans la jeunesse
alors où les gens s'entretuent en
banlieue on sait même plus pourquoi à
l'heure où les jeunes sont confinés
aussi c'est vrai pour protéger les lieux
qui sont de plus en plus lieu on se
demande
il faut il faut repenser moi je pense
parce que je le dis souvent que le
xxième siècle sera kémaliste où ce sera
la barbade
qu'est ce qu'elle représente et bien
c'est un grave de d'une artiste
américain au bay qui l'a réalisé on est
quelques temps après les attentats du 13
novembre 2015 qui se sont donc déroulées
à paris en seine saint denis et donc il
fait une sorte de don artistique
donc pour la ville de paris qui a été
endeuillée et je trouve déjà d'un point
de vue esthétique extrêmement fort ce
geste très beau très réussi et puis
évidemment on est là avec la devise
républicaine qui passe par un artiste
américain ce qui est quand même toujours
intéressant et puis et puis peut-être
surtout pour moi c'est s'est inscrit
dans l'espace public c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas dans du politique
on est avec un artiste qui décide de
faire un geste qui reste dans l'espace
public et donc pour justement pour le
public en tant que tel oh mais c'est lui
qui avait fait ouest oui il y as we can
exact images logos avec barack obama
comme ab et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir que un autre artiste américain
va vouloir la même chose quelques années
plus tard c'est jeff koons avec le
bouquet de tulipes
sauf qu'on va lui reprocher de vouloir
le mettre un endroit un peu trop
avantageux pour lui et on veut finir par
accepter le cadeau mais à un autre
endroit
mais la démarche est la même mais
décalés dans le temps oui tout à fait tu
le fish
oui une affiche un peu ambivalente parce
qu'on est entre la publicité de mode et
la fiche pour une exposition pour ceux
qui ne le savent peut-être pas et du
mythe langue est un grand créateur de
mode des années 80 90 qui a été ce soir
deux chantres du minimalisme subversif
qui est depuis devenu une forme une
sorte d'icône pour les plus jeunes
générations et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est donc saint laurent la marque
qui a fait appel à cette collaboration
avec helmut lang
on est dans le dialogue art contemporain
mode qui quitteraient très prégnant dans
notre société
depuis quelques années mais c'est
intéressant parce que là on n'a pas à
faire un artiste lambda on a affaire un
créateur de mode un ancien créateur de
mode qui a arrêté la mode mais tout de
même qui reste un monde de la mode et ce
qui est intéressant encore plus dans
cette démarche c'est que en fait les
sculptures ont été réalisés à partir des
rebuts enfin en tout cas des déchets par
des déchets raffiné de la maison c'est à
dire les prototypes les modèles que l'on
ne vend pas et donc en fait on est aussi
dans cette question qui se pose sur la
pollution que créer l'industrie textile
et comment est-ce qu'on peut donner une
ayem lui à ces déchets textiles ces
déchets de mode l'image que vous avez
choisi je crois qu'elle figure dans
votre album non ah non non non mais
c'est l'image que j'ai créée pour
l'occasion en fait qu'ils savent enfin
que j'ai nommé l'être humain en devenir
et pour réaliser un désir
pardon pourquoi en devenir
c'est une vision de ce que pourrait être
humain l'être humain du futur si on
extrapole à partir de notre époque
donc les digital autocentré c'est pas
transsexuels ou un transgenre
c'est à la fois un homme et une femme en
fait il s'est fait modifier le corps
pour le plaisir
enfin dans pas par nécessité quoi et ce
serait une forme de transhumanisme
fantaisiste chez team kardashian ou
d'autres n'ait mais là ce serait l'étape
d'après en fait c'est une courbe de
coordonner série de courbes donc c'est
une série s'est scellée fonction
exponentielle
donc c'est une esthétique toute relative
mais je crois que dans l'époque actuelle
c'est une course qui est en train de
devenir importance avec les épidémies
suivent des lois exponentielle en phase
épidémique ce nombre de cas en fonction
du temps mais c'est aussi le sait aussi
les courbes qui vont décrire par exemple
le l'activité d'un matériau fissile ans
dans une boue ou l'augmentation de la
consommation des ressources ou
l'augmentation de l'accumulation de
richesses des personnes les plus riches
d'une société donc c'est les courbes qui
sont qui sont importantes et qui ont
cette propriété d'être un peu difficile
a ensuite essayé on a du mal à partir de
la gauche de la courbe où tout semble
aller très bien à imaginer la
catastrophe qui vient c'est la courbe de
la catastrophe à venir et c'est pas une
courbe dont les humains sont je pense
ont spontanément habitué à anticiper
l'avenir donc ça suppose un niveau
d'abstraction important et dont je crois
que politiquement c'est une question
comment est ce qu'on fait pour prendre
des décisions politiques
ça des processus qui suivent ce type de
loi on l'a vu avec le co lead comment
est ce qu'on met en place un confinement
quand on a que 40 ou 50 personnes
malades mais qu'on sait que dans une
quinzaine de jours y en aura 4000 ou
5000 et comment est ce qu'on fait pour
agir sur le réchauffement climatique
quand on voit pas les six nous on n'en
voit que les prémices voilà donc je
crois que ces décès les cours auxquels
on va avoir à faire de plus en plus et
qui pose des questions politiques une
certaine manière il va falloir aussi
apprendre à les lire ses courbes parce
que tout dépend de la graduation
on peut faire monter une courbe exane
est aucun sens quand il y avait un
malade du coc vide si le lendemain il y
en avait 4 évidemment la courbe monter
considérablement mais ça faisait quand
même que ça que malade à la fin ça
n'était pas sain mille fois j'espère
aller milliards à vous avez il faut
apprendre à dire mais justement les
courbes exponentielle de certaines
manières si vous décalez l'axé un peu si
vous projetez une semaine après
finalement ça change pas grand chose à
dire que la catastrophe arrive à une
distance n'est pas très différente
par exemple si vous prenez la france et
l'italie pendant un temps au début du
mois de mars
on avait huit jours d'écart sur les
progressions ça veut dire que huit jours
à peine on est au niveau l'italie
mais les italiens étaient déjà dans la
catastrophe que nous on vivait
tranquillement sans savoir que huit
jours plus tard on serait confinée en
fait les physiciens par exemple savait
déjà qu'on serait confinée dans les
laboratoires les gens savaient déjà
qu'on serait confinée huit ou dix jours
avant parce que la progression était
clairement exponentielle et donc on
pouvait se projeter
mais évidemment ça suppose et c'est là
où c'est difficile c'est que ça suppose
une compréhension mathématiques parce
que l'intuition ne peut pas grand-chose
et dont je crois qu'il ya derrière et
aussi la question de la culture
mathématique et physique et c'est une
question qui était difficile donc c'est
une de vos oeuvres
en fait c'est une oeuvre que j'ai pinte
la veille du confinement et que j'avais
préparé pendant plusieurs jours
auparavant mais moi c'est pour battre
personnel c'est l'image qui a marqué mon
année parce que
on traduit des fois des choses qu'on ne
mesure pas et on a vu s'ouvrir ce virus
arrive et d'asie c'est pour ça que les
modèles de la photographie que j'ai
utilisée pour près cette oeuvre
ce sont deux personnages asiatiques et
j'ai senti qu'il fallait que je
travaille sur ce thème et quand j'ai vu
les choses arriver jusqu'en italie et je
les peintres la veille du confinement et
depuis j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'on a basculé dans un autre monde en
fait
ou sous une autre forme de prégnance de
avec là on va dire l'hyper focalisation
sanitaires et on y encore puisqu'on est
sur le point le livre un nouvel épisode
vous qui vous marquera tous sa licence
de rendre compte de sable est il de leur
du temps à dominante il ya deux éléments
d'une part le masque auquel nous sommes
tous contraints depuis déjà un certain
temps et ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'information en quelque sorte main
stream qui est qui et surtout les médias
qui est la question du séparatisme de
l'islam de la laïcité et il ne sommes
que sont les deux sujets dominants qui
sont traités par les médias de masse ces
derniers temps et dans une même qui
m'est apparu que cette image constitue
en quelque sorte un concentré des deux
est évidemment l'alliance des deux
n'exprime pas de prime abord principe de
liberté n'exprime pas un principe de
société parfaitement assumé on a parlé
un instant du chaos
il a ainsi qu'une forme de chaos c'est
la fermeture est me semble-t-il de
surcroît c'est une synthèse de
des confusion ambiante c'est à dire que
ici et là sur les réseaux sociaux dont
on en parlait ce type d'image est
assortie de commentaires selon lequel en
quelque sorte on y aurait une
contradiction à interdire la burqa et à
imposer le masque sanitaire comme si ces
deux questions relever du même registre
et je pense évidemment des deux
questions sont totalement différentes et
que faire une analyse commentaires
politiques soulignant une contradiction
crois même que le washington post a
raillé en quelque sorte la france
d'imposer le masque au moment même où on
voulait interdire la burqa or pour moi
c'est évidemment une forme de confusion
qui d'une certaine manière
[Musique]
et tu n es qu raccourcira beaucoup de
confusion qui me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui domine dans un certain
nombre de représentations société celle
ci je vois bien ou ce qu'elle représente
mais pourquoi celle-ci bah écoutez moi
j'avais une photocopie talent on me
présente cet hôpital qui convient tout à
fait alors bon aujourd'hui on sait très
bien pourquoi on peut choisir cette
image mais je crois que je l'aurais
choisi avant la pandémie parce que on
est une époque qui est dans un idéal de
longévité
c'est vrai que c'est très frappant de
voir que les les directeurs les patrons
des gaffes à mes créateurs dégâts femmes
leur rêve suprême c'est la longévité
c'est l'éternité
c'est la première fois que une espèce
animale si j'ose dire
son idéal c'est longévité c'est la
première fois qu'on imagine allonger la
durée de vie d'une espèce de mammifère
parce que par exemple vous avez les
éléphants qui vivent peut vivre jusqu'à
100 ans mais celica depuis l'origine des
éléphants tandis que nous notre rêve
c'est un rêve de longévité c'est à dire
on a le rêve de durée voilà et avant on
avait ce rêve de durée et de perdurer à
travers sa ligne et sa descendance
les rois qui crée une qui crée un
royaume les empereur napoléon voulais
durer mais par an vivent éternellement
il voulait que son fils lui succède et
le fils de son fils et c'est nous c'est
nous mêmes qui vont nous succéder à
nous-mêmes éternellement mais je pense
que l'hôpital symbolise en même temps se
réfugier au frais avant on révèle lé
père ni té mais dans l'au delà
la quête d'immortels voilà un au fond
est aussi ancienne on pourrait dire que
que l'humanité oui mais pas
l'immortalité ici bas si je veux dire je
pense que c'est la première fois on a
essayé toujours de guérir des maladies
mais maintenant on en est à vouloir
changer le programme même de lune
c'est à dire qui est programmé soit
disant pour vivre 120 ans mais par
exemple des gens les gens dégâts femmes
ne sont pas satisfaits parce que en
réalité je pense aussi quand on est
extrêmement riche
on ne comprend pas pourquoi on va mourir
pour ça qu'il ya des gens riches qui
vont faire congeler leurs leur corps
parce que comme ils peuvent tout acheter
ils comprennent pas que ça il
ils sont même rang que que l'ouvrier du
coin ou que le cadre du coin ou que
leurs employés et je pense que c'est
très s'est réduit à ça et en même temps
on arrive à ajouter foi à des
imbécilités sous prétexte que ça va être
des gens qui ont qui sont à la base de
google ou de je ne sais quoi c'est à
dire que ce serait n'importe qui qui
raconterait les choses qui raconte on
les enverrais se faire voir mais comme
ils ont réussi dans la vie on les écoute
par exemple j'ai entendu cette
imbécillité de quelqu'un qui travaille
chez google mais un très haut niveau qui
était un des patrons derrière qui disait
que dans dix ans les gens n'offrait plus
l'amour parce qu'ils pourraient se
connecter sur des machines qui les
effraie les prouvé beaucoup plus de
jouissance c'est évidemment complètement
stupide
voilà mais comme c'était quelqu'un issu
des gars femmes eh ben on l'a écouté
plus mystérieuse il s'agit du test le
plus fiable pour identifier la présence
duco vide 19 est un chien est le premier
à première expérience concluante a eu
lieu pendant le confinement on a affrété
un eurostar pour transporter un plombier
de melun et sa chienne il a et sidi
driss hic le monsieur en question avait
dressé cette chienne a comme lui détecte
et son blues de détecter les fuites de
gaz et sa chienne le faisait beaucoup
plus rapidement que lui david distance
impressionnante même je vous allez
rester pour les cancers détectés les
textes concernant la prostate et de la
vessie et la une un laboratoire anglais
l'a fait venir est la tesla chienne a
passé les tests avec succès elle a très
vite reconnu parmi plusieurs
échantillons la molécule de co vite
qu'on lui avait fait respirer d'abord et
ensuite comme vous savez les suspects
qui sont derrière un mur il ya plusieurs
personnes et elle a identifié la
personne qui était porteur un porteur
sain mais comment y accueillir de l'aca
se développe partout comment
explique-t-on parce que en fait ça n'a
pas d'odeur le le le virus ben bien sûr
que si pour un chien pour nous non mais
pour les chiens capables de détecter
comme ils le font couramment aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux des cancers du sein de
de la prostate de la vessie notamment
avec 100 % de réussite
la différence des autres tests ils sont
capable de renifler explosif on a été
sauvé de nombreux attentats à paris
grâce à cette brigade canine de chiens
détecteurs d'explosifs y compris les
explosifs qu'on ne peut pas détecter
comme les dérivés de centex et ou dans
les moyens traditionnels et les chiens
détecte même les l'épilepsie les crises
d'épilepsie avant même que les symptômes
soient soient détectables donc le flair
autres shows sont aussi les ondes
électromagnétiques en ce qui concerne le
ce qui se passe dans le cerveau du
patient et aujourd'hui voilà on a dans
plein d'endroits douze pays ont demandé
à acide idrissi donc ce plombier de
melun de venir tester les chiens la
russie notamment
et lui est ce que je sois merveille dans
sa réponse il a dit moi je préfère
rester mais je veux 6 hectares pour
mettre tout ça en oeuvre et que ce soit
la réinsertion de noms que qu'ils soient
au centre de tout le personnel que je
veux employés là dedans
donc on peut aussi avoir de très belles
aventures sur fond de kovy des de
confinement comme je le raconte dans mon
livre c'est vrai que ce chien enfin un
chien qui a ce pouvoir là un rôle assez
important dans le livre et je pense
qu'il est bon de rappeler dans ces
périodes anxiogène que les solutions
existent et qu'elles peuvent être aussi
apporté un émerveillement qui nous fait
du bien c'est un paysan c'est un
campagne oui on en fait ces deux images
qui viennent de la presse régionale
l'une de la première tout en haut de var
matin et la deuxième de la provence pour
montrer que finalement la question du
risque à l'égard du loup est une
question qui est très inégale en france
et qui est supporté en particulier par
la périphérie du territoire j'entends
les alpes
évidemment à commencer par les alpes du
sud
et maintenant de plus en plus le massif
central et le jura et le bassin parisien
or la question du loup est évidemment
une question dont sont victimes les
bergers et les éleveurs notamment pas
uniquement notamment ce qui élève des
brebis et des boutons et ces images
montrent que quelles que soient les
protections qui sont prises à l'égard du
loup notamment avec les chiens patous
avec les parcs électrifiés vient
n'arrête le prédateur dont
l'intelligence en quelque sorte lui
permet de contourner petit à petit
évidemment à force d'expériences les
obstacles que l'on y met et donc on a un
milieu professionnel en véritable
détresse celui des bergers et des
éleveurs de une bonne vingtaine de
départements français actuellement et
ebel davantage qui sont confrontés à ces
attaques de loups à l'égard desquels ils
ne peuvent rien faire et y voir
évidemment leurs brebis qui sont
éventrés dévorer ou fortement blessé
parce que quand le loup attaque il ya un
réflexe surplus skilling qui fait que
voyons le stress en quelque sorte des
animaux il se met à mordre à blesser
voire à tuer beaucoup plus d'animaux
qu'il n'en a besoin pour consommer en
série table drame que l'on voit pas
beaucoup en ville qui d'ailleurs
apparaît assez peu dans les débats
publics nationaux mais qui en revanche
intervient beaucoup au niveau régional
et ce qui m'intéressait ici c'est de
montrer que cette question du loup elle
divise véritablement elle la population
sur la façon de le gérer et de
l'accepter à une période où son statut
juridique a été diamétralement à verser
par rapport aux statuts négatif qui
était le sien pendant des siècles et des
siècles et donc comme on fait peser à
une minorité de la population
les choix de société et les choix
d'environnement qui sont les nôtres au
niveau européen puisque le loup est une
espèce strictement protégée au niveau
européen
je pense qu à toute une réflexion à
avoir quand même pour montrer que cet
animal symbolique qui est à la fois un
animal du passé et peut-être de l'avenir
qu'ils défient les hommes et qui les
pousse finalement à la compréhension
aourag mathis mme et je dirais un peu à
l'intelligence alors de quoi s'agit-il
c'est un robot dans un parc à à
singapour qui est là pour contrôler les
gens et leur demander de respecter la
distanciation sociale et c'est un robot
qui est développé par boston dynamics
qui est une société américaine qui je me
suis intéressé parce que j'ai commencé à
travailler à 9 ans sur mon fils et comme
j'avais un personnage de roboticiens n
est que je voulais intégrer des
véritables robots dans le film je me
suis intéressé à ce que faisait cette
société qui complètement hallucinant et
un peu effrayant j'avais un ami qui
m'avait fait découvrir sa et qui me
disait tu imagines le jour où ou leur
chien viendra de chercher chez toi parce
que pour te contrôler ou pour et puis
finalement le temps a passé neuf ans se
sont écoulés et on a fini par voir cette
image dans la réalité
et voilà alors j'ai pas pu collaborer
avec eux pour mon film malheureusement
mais on a créer nos propres robots mais
mais qu'on voulait assez réaliste
l'image la voici alors où c'était et
pourquoi les avez-vous choisi là c'est
une image de ce pays où j'ai été que
j'ai dont j'ai gardé un excellent
souvenir après il y met beaucoup de
respect à un pays où en dignité dans la
population et que j'ai beaucoup aimé ces
somalie hassan ali et il y à tête cette
image de tron est en fait et termine
beaucoup plus qu'on imagine la politique
et la sécurité dans nos pays puisque et
c'est drôle ce sont ces drones qui
encouragent en définitive les
terroristes à venir exercer
et chez nous leurs entre guillemets et
adam pourquoi parce qu'ils estiment que
par les drones au fond nous faisons la
même chose chez eux que ce qu'il
pourrait faire chez nous en posant des
bombes ou en mitraillant les gens dans
les rues
alors en vérité il de faire pression sur
les populations occidentales pour que
ces populations demandent à leur pays de
cesser de bombarder et c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé en france il y a cinq
ans en attendant le libère cacher et à
charlie hebdo
c'est ce qui s'est passé un peu partout
en europe c'est en fait cette manière de
faire la guerre que nous avons à
l'encontre d'ailleurs du droit
international et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
la seule le seul outil que ces théories
sont trouvés bons ou mauvais c'est
d'essayer d'influencer à leur tour dans
le sens inverse les opinions
occidentales
les sages c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
eux qui le disent ils l'ont un bip dans
leurs écrits on le trouve ça dans leur
publication
mais aussi dans les vidéos qui ont été
diffusés partiellement en occident dont
on est d'ailleurs toujours enlever ce
passage dans les vidéos qu'on a montré
on a montré les horreurs n'en a pas
montré le message des terroristes et où
il explique pourquoi il frappe chine
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec une
domination mondiale une guerre sainte
contre l'occident ou une domination
mondiale
ça c'est une c on entre déjà là dans le
domaine des fausses vérités où on essaye
en fait d'esquiver la responsabilité
occidental dans cette réaction par le
terrorisme n'est rien d'autre qu'une
réaction à des actions occidentales
vous avez choisi cette image une famille
alors qu'est ce qu'elle est particulier
pour vous elle m'intéresse pas ce qu'on
voit les mélanges quoi on voit les
mélanges de gens d'origines différentes
on voit les métissages et donc c'est
aussi ce que je retrace dans mon livre
c'est toutes ces histoires des
migrations et des mélanges
jeu au fil de l'aventuré de notre espèce
oui là ils ont l'air tout ce blanc mais
en fait aucun ne l'est réellement 1
ils sont tous mélangés ils sont tous
mélangés en tous les cas oui on a une
bonne partie qui sont bien mélanger et
tant mieux quoi
[Musique]
c'est dans la série les selphy on en a
eu quelques-unes quelques uns plus
exactement depuis le début de cette
émission alors pourquoi ce pourquoi ce
self il a fait par une femme frédéric
sojcher je savourais par un homme aussi
par un couple la question c'est celle de
narcissisme de notre époque et que je
poserai à la création parce que les
écrivains les cinéastes et artistes
peuvent parler d'eux à la première
personne n'ait à condition de se
dépasser
trouver la bonne distance hélas souvent
dans les personnes qui ont laissé les
fils et c'est juste la négo sans aucune
création et sans aucun intérêt et je
voudrais aussi dire que quand je donne
cours à mes étudiants la sorbonne au
cinéma maintenant grâce aux appareils de
téléphone on peut on peut filmer très
facilement mais ça ne suffit pas la
technique doit être au service d'un
propos sied pas de propos la technique
d'un connecteur pas les réseaux sociaux
mais ce sont des téléphones portables ça
ressemble un peu moi je me promène
beaucoup de marche énormément à rue dans
la ville
je vois que des visages fermés que des
visages baisser si on ajoute à ça les
oreillettes le masque les lunettes de
soleil si la canicule
les gens sont complètement fermés
aujourd'hui demander un renseignement
dans la rue à quelqu'un ça devient
compliqué le téléphone portable iphone
est devenu un espèce de coach personnel
et je me demande quelle était sa peut
faire sur les enfants sur les jeunes sur
les ados c'est sa coupe en fait
complètement les ados ça mais d'un côté
le monde des jeunes et de leur côté le
monde des adultes ont par exemple moi
quand j'étais gamin quand je me faisais
engueuler par mon père en fait via une
confrontation
je m'excuse et où je me discuter ou je
filais dans ma chambre est pas qu elle
apporte aujourd'hui en fait il suffit
juste de regarder son portable pour
clore une programmation tino qui nous
dérange et je me demande vraiment
comment mais comment les gamins vont
grandir avec ce ce coach personnel en
sexe et et si j'ai choisi cet objet
c'est tout simplement parce que moi
c'est un objet qui a une influence
vraiment dans ma vie de tous les jours
parce que je le subis
moi moi j'en ai pas j'aime pas ça etc
mais je veux subi je suis obligé de
vivre avec ça prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur c'est un peu une image
caricaturale et en vain en hyper
réaliste ce ne sont pas les robots
d'amazones que l'on voit dans les rues
ce ne sont pas les drones ce sont des
des vélocipédistes d'hubert de des
libéraux voilà c'est une phase non
cachée de la société digital celle qui
nous rend service mais qui aussi rabat
les cartes sur le marché du travail qui
ramène la régulation de l'état dans
l'entreprise dans heavy rain qui éveille
interpelle en matière de droit social
voilà c'est notre l'extension de notre
liberté avec le digital repose la
question aussi du vivre ensemble et qui
travaille pour qui alors cette photo
c'est une femme de dos qui
vraisemblablement allaite son bébé au
milieu du chaos en fait une photo qui a
été prise en 2015 dans le camp de moria
par ma soeur qui photo reporter ma soeur
khloé street art as deviennent et
je trouve que c'est une photo qui est
d'une certaine façon illustre notre
époque parce que c'est un perce une
personne individuelle qui est
complètement abandonné par la société et
ça rappelle aujourd'hui que ce camp de
moria a été incendiée le 9 septembre
2001 la gare mois et demi parce que les
les réfugiés et les migrants qui était
dedans on pouvait plus et est du coup là
ils ont été mis dans un autre camp qui
est tout aussi horrible dans des
conditions sanitaires horrible voilà et
voilà c'est un peu les oubliés du duc o
vite de cette crise on parle beaucoup de
cette crise de notre propre confort et
on oublie celui des plus démunis qui fit
chez eux la guerre là là et tout les
tous les maux et qui qui se retrouvent
parqués dans des concentrés voilà tant d
années sans avenir sans rien milieu du
chaos
c'est ans et en ethiopie jetaient un peu
la bande annonce de ce que vous allez
nous de ce que vous racontez dans votre
livre
oui exactement comprendre pourquoi
est-ce que des institutions
internationales comme l'unesco le wwf
lui cn recommande l'expulsion de
villages et de villageois comme ceux de
gi joe en ethiopie donc l'avant là prêt
pour soi disant lutter contre la
dégradation écologique en s'en prenant
des paysans qui malheureusement ne
participe pas alors on le voit c'était
du temps où il y avait encore des
habitants dans ce parc national en
dessous c'est quand il n'y en a plus et
puis il ya une troisième photo vous
vouliez con qu'on regarde
la voici alors ça c'est une fois que le
pacte national est devenu un parc
national et qui est des touristes oui
voilà et c'est pour souligner le
paradoxe quand beaucoup dix ans de gens
qui sont surpris hier en se disant bon
certes il y à des expulsions des
déplacements mais en même temps la
nature est protégé sauf que si on fait
le calcul du coût écologique de la
visite d'un parc en afrique
donc ce qui hélas cette photographie
bien les bâtons d'aluminium pour ces
tentes mais c'est de l'extraction de
bauxite
les randonneurs qui diront une veste en
gore-tex du téflon la veste la petite
polaires des résidus de pétrole
le billet en avion 0,5 tonne de co2
généralement un smartphone donc encore
de l'extraction de matières premières
bien finalement venir visiter un parc
naturel en afrique c'est l'équivalent de
détruire dans le monde
les ressources qui sont protégés dans ce
parc d'où l'absurdité sociale mais aussi
finalement écologique est peut-être les
parcs serait davantage des trompe l'oeil
qui masque le vrai problème la
dégradation massive de l'environnement
sur toute la planète
c'est babar pourquoi barça pourrait pas
à paraître cocasse mais en fait j'ai
choisi babar
parce que en fin de semaine dernière sur
sur france culture il ya eu une émission
qui a parlé du célèbre dessin animé
qu'on connaît tous et que
personnellement je l'adoré quand j'étais
enfant et et qui l'accusé d'incarner
l'apologie du colonialisme
pour une raison qui était que baba après
avoir adopter les coutumes des humains
rentrer dans sa forêt devient le roi et
apprend aux autres éléphants à se
civiliser
et selon moi ce type d'idéologie est
assez assez révélateur de l'époque dans
laquelle on vit où il ya de nouvelles
idéologies qui apparaissent comme comme
l'indigénisme comme le des colonnades ou
de des colonialismes l'antispécisme la
cancel culture qui ont émergé aux états
unis et qui arrivent petit à petit en
france notamment dans les universités et
je voulais voilà passé un petit clin
d'oeil à babar puisque c'est un
phénomène qui personnellement
mme intéressés ils inquiètent de plus en
plus alors c'est un film milk mjc le
prochain film de bruno podalydès qui
s'appelle les deux alfred je venais de
voir ce film quand vous m'avez demandé
de donner mon image qui caractérise
l'époque c'est un film de légère
anticipation et j'ai l'impression qu'on
vide dans le futur aujourd'hui vraiment
c'est à dire qu'on imaginait les années
2000 2005 avec des voitures en train de
flotter dans les airs et en fait on se
rend compte que pas du tout mais d'un
autre côté tout ce qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment depuis quelques temps
on a l'impression que c'est dans un
bouquin de caddies quoi et cette image
pour moi c'est celle aussi de la
fraternité ce que raconte aussi le film
non pas la fraternité entre bruno
podalydès qu'on voit sur la photo à
à droite et denis podalydès à gauche
c'est la fraternité choisie c'est-à-dire
dans le film ils sont pas frères et ils
deviennent une famille d'une certaine
manière avec sandrine kiberlain qui joue
le troisième rôle et c'est une manière
d'inventer une nouvelle vie quand le
futur nous pousse à l'envisager
et j'ai l'impression qu'on est vraiment
dans cette situation aujourd'hui
comment imaginer réinventer nos vies
réinventer l'avenir qui nous semblent ne
pas vouloir exister ou se boucher quoi
et votre image avoue jean françois
colossimo mais c'était ya pas très
longtemps à ces pays istanbul
voilà on est près de l'ancienne
université d'istanbul près du grand
bazar et je dirais que c'est pas nos
marques
au fond la question qu'on peut adresser
à l'état turc avant même que
adressée aux turcs eux mêmes bon nous
sommes du côté l'azerbaïdjan ont dit
l'une pourquoi pas mais l'autre dit stop
à l'agression arménienne et avec une
demande de justice
or je veux dire c'est assez sage ce sont
les arméniens du haut karabagh qui ont
été agressée certe l'affairé complexe
autant qu'on voudra mais ce sont eux qui
en fait sont dans la position inverse à
celle que décrit cette pancarte est en
fait au but là sur une certaine
réécriture de l'histoire qui est tout à
fait de mise en turquie et qui voient là
le turc comme une victime comme
quelqu'un d'encercler comme quelqu'un
d'agressé de l'extérieur de l'intérieur
et ce turc
je dirais encerclé en fait il se montra
nous un peu comme pour le coup enfermé
dans une sorte de contre histoire qui
explique cette mobilisation nationaliste
constante d'atatürk heures de gueule
voici l'image que vous avez choisie elle
a fait le tour du monde
alors pourquoi celle-ci et ben justement
parce qu'elle a fait le tour du monde
je trouvais ça intéressant dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui je vous présente
des photos d'histoire à l'époque où à la
photographie été créés dont exceptionnel
je vous présente même pas les toutes
premières photos là ce qui est
impressionnant je trouve dans le
phénomène de jack et angeli que tout le
monde connaît maintenant très répandu
une semaine son visage a fait le tour de
la planète et je trouvais ça intéressant
est symptomatique de notre société
actuelle où il ya une sur représentation
de l'image où l'image et partager
instantanément et reproductibles ce qui
n'était pas le cas on ne fera peut-être
tout à l'heure avec les daguerréotypes
et que et que ça apporte aussi des
travers pour notre société qui est
beaucoup dans l'émotion beaucoup dans
l'instantané beaucoup dans la photo sans
explications parfois sans contexte et
qui peuvent amener à une manipulation
des foules comme je trouve que ça peut
ça peut amener à fragiliser nos
démocraties occidentales et qu'on l'a
bien vu mercredi dernier avec 7 à chaud
du capital et puis il faut dire que la
photo s'est fortement banalise et
surtout depuis ce début de xxième siècle
tout le monde ayant un appareil photo
dans sa poche mais tout à coup les
photos qui viennent mémorable ce sont
celles qui justement quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et c'est le cas de celle
ci bien entendu tout à fait ça c'est ce
que c'est la partie qui en commun avec
mon livre c'est que si cette photo a
fait le tour du monde c'est aussi parce
que elle est exceptionnel parce que elle
elle marque les esprits et c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire avec le livre que
je vais vous présenter aujourd'hui c'est
à dire montrer seulement des photos qui
marque vraiment l'histoire et qui a qui
interpellent et qui ont un petit effet
whaou de quoi s'agit-il ce qu'une
peinture ou juste une photo et un
marathon c'est une photo une photo qui
parle d'elle même je crois on y va
donald trump vu de dos cette photo
explique tout d'un côté la grandeur
américaine c'est un petit pas les bras
ballants la défaite c'est ce que j'aime
dans cette photo c'est qu'elle n'a même
pas besoin d'être légende et on se doute
que ce qui arrive à l'homme qu'il ya des
photographies on dirait presque une
illustration norman rockwell way et j'ai
choisi également cette photo depuis le
départ donc définitif et récent de
valéry giscard d'estaing le départ qui
avait été marqué par ses propos à la
télévision
on est un petit peu dans la même
situation les bras le long du corps on
voit toute la détresse tout là la misère
qui tombe sur un seul homme et qui s'en
va comme ça presque de manière blood
j'aime beaucoup cette photo c'est un
point qui nous rappelle quelque chose
rien n'est ce pas bah oui c'est l'image
de deux jeunes démagogues qui se sont
présentés aux élections présidentielles
américaines et qui ont la particularité
l'un et l'autre de représenter le peuple
alors quand on les écoute on se demande
de quel peuple américain il se
breclav ou celui qui veulent servir ou
défendre les intérêts parce qu'on n'a
pas l'impression qu'ils parlent du même
peuple à chaque fois c'est ray est très
étrange
je me demande si celle ci le mot peuple
en lui même n'est pas déjà en lui-même
un vocable démagogique qui permet et
bien justement de ratisser le plus large
possible
et voilà c'est une sorte de vocables le
creux dans lequel on met finalement le
sens que l'on veut la catégorie sociale
que l'on désire
celle qui nous arrange le mur de la
clientèle en fait qui arrange qui
arrange le mieux le démocrate si vous
voulez voilà et oui c'est d'un autre
homme qui joue au golf au moment où on
annonce qu'il a sans doute perdu
l'élection
alors je trouverais que ça aurait été
une bonne façon pour lui juste après
cette partie flamboyante d'accepter les
résultats peut-être et qu'il aurait fini
sur un espèce de comme ça deux de pique
mes mots apparemment il refuse donc mais
voilà presque sympathique sur sur cette
photo et sur l'a6 avait fini comme ça ça
va je pense qu'on a été plutôt positif
pour mieux mais bon il ne peut pas y
parle pas mais il n'a jamais reconnu
aucune défaite donald trump vois pas
pourquoi il commencera aujourd'hui
jamais jamais donc cesser cette photo
est ce ça aurait été magistral comme
sortie de finhan là dessus ni rationnel
irrationnelle finira sans doute là
dessus
la russie là aussi ça s'effrite nicolas
oui en effet ça me semble assez bien
résumé ce qui s'est passé durant les six
derniers mois il ne suffit pas de ne
suffit pas de d'applaudir à 20h et de
dire que l'on va changer etc
on voit bien que quelques mois plus tard
le naturel revient au galop et que le
que les chantres du néolibéralisme
ne peuvent pas ne peuvent pas s'empêcher
de reconsidérer l'hôpital public et des
travailleurs comme des comme des chargés
comme des coûts et là sont des
infirmières c'est vite passé la
parenthèse est vite passé ce sont des
infirmières un convoi sur cette image
oui tout à fait c'est le président de la
république emmanuel macron face à l'as
douanes
oui c'est une image qui demande une
explication nous vivons dans une
illusion intellectuelle collective nous
pensons que le retour des frontières
puisque le monde est tellement
inquiétant nous aidera à mieux maîtriser
notre destin
et quand on y réfléchit les grandes
crises auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
la crise écologique évidemment la crise
sanitaire le terrorisme aussi sont des
crises qui se moque des frontières et
des nationalités
évidemment la crise écologique que nous
la résoudrons que s'il y a des décisions
communes qui sont prises au niveau de la
planète c'est la même chose pour la
crise sanitaire et la lutte contre le
coc vide et même le terrorisme suppose
plutôt que des douaniers qu'hypothétique
m'en arrêter des gens qui auraient des
mauvais calcul sur tel ou tel pays
une collaboration importante entre des
services secrets des appareils policiers
la syrie et la france pour parler de la
france la france et l'algérie
la france et l'egypte et donc les
frontières qui sont une espèce de corde
de rappel intellectuelle aujourd'hui
dans le débat
le retour de ceux des souverainetés ce
qui d'ailleurs nous ramène au général de
gaulle est une illusion d'optique parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les énergies
qu'il faut fédérer au niveau de la
planète et nous sommes dans un
contresens total avec le réarmement leur
réapparition de nos frontières
la contestation de la libre circulation
des individus
hélas s'il suffisait de quelques
douaniers pour régler nos problèmes ce
serait formidable nous tomberons de haut
quand nous le comprendrons
c'est un portrait de julian assange
pourquoi lui un jeune snc quelqu'un déjà
bonjour personne chez quelqu'un qui
occupe une place très importante dans
mon coeur et dans ma réflexion sur la
nouveauté politique au xxème siècle au
21ème siècle je pense que wikileaks a
été l'une des organisations les plus
puissantes et les plus déstabilisatrice
pour essayer de réfléchir sur l'état de
droit de savoir sur la connaissance
l'espace public sur le journalisme sur
l'anonymat et puis bien sûr en ce moment
il ya son procès dans lequel il risque
d'être extradé aux états unis d'être
peut-être condamnés à plus de 150 ans de
prison ce qui m'intéresse moi beaucoup
avec la figure de jane assène sur la
figure de la dissidence politique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
traditionnellement dans l'histoire de la
dissidence que ce soit en afrique du sud
avec mandela que ce soit les dissidents
soviétiques
il avait toujours une référence qui
était un peu les pays européens où les
etats-unis comme le lieu d'accueil comme
le modèle dont il pouvait se servir et
invoqué contre les systèmes répressifs
qui les réprimaient et contre lequel il
se battait méprendre quand une figure
comme julian assange en a à faire à des
dissidents des états qui étaient
présentés comme les modèles des anciens
dissidents c'est les états unis et c'est
l'angleterre qui le persécutent ce sont
des juges indépendants c'est l'état de
droit qui s'applique et qui risque de
mettre en prison 150 ans est donc allée
d'iéna scène j'en ai un peu à faire à la
réouverture de l'histoire politique
parce que on est lucide en décidant
orphelin de tout modèle et de tout futur
des dissidences sans patrie d'accueil
possibles sans modèle politique plus
démocratique qui pourraient les
accueillir
et donc pour moi jen hassan chez
vraiment un peu l'enjeu le défi qui se
pose à nos systèmes politiques
aujourd'hui c'est de quelle manière est
ce que nous pourrions réinventer les
états la souveraineté le droit de savoir
pourquoi un modèle comme lui puisse
vivre et puissent pleinement exercer sa
profession et non pas être en présent
être menacée de mort de quoi s'agit-il
une bagarre générale parce que j'ai
l'impression que y'a pus trop de socle
de valeurs communes comme dans la
société que j'ai toujours connu où le
débat et la confrontation existait mais
où on arrivait à former une société à
peu près cohérente
aujourd'hui tout le monde se frite avec
tout le monde alors on choisit une
communauté 11 victimes ils ont un peu et
chacun pour sa gueule donc les antilles
masque contre les pros masquer les laïcs
contre les croyants qui s'allie aux
antilles charlie contre les pros charlie
les féministes abolo contre les pro sexe
les indigéniste à poils durs contre les
suprématistes à poil ras j'en passe un
vous voyez à peu près l'idée et pendant
ce temps là bas je pense que le pouvoir
mange des pop corn en nous regardant ce
nous friter voilà
de quoi s'agit-il au côté de qui alors
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas de qui il
s'agit sur cette photo mais ne pouvant
pas choisir parmi tous les désastres
dont bono notre invité pour nous parler
je suis retombé sur cette photo que
j'avais acheté dans une brocante au cape
code donc là en pleine élection
américaine je trouvais que c'était un
bon clin d'oeil et en même temps cette
photo résume assez bien notre époque
pour moi elle est pleine de d'absurdité
assez agressive aussi de narcissisme
d'une forme de solitude aussi un un peu
pathétique
d'obscénité le fusil pas la fleur au
fusil non la cigarette au chili et je
trouvais que c'était pour pour mon sujet
s'était pas mal il faut d une photo
illustrant les grands incendies récents
ne sait pas si la ce et l'australie l'an
passé où la californie il ya quelques
semaines c'est plutôt excitant que ces
immenses ses immenses incendies
symbolisme le réchauffement climatique
mais plus généralement le problème
écologique la catastrophe écologique
annoncée
ce qui n'est pas mon sens une raison
pour renoncer à toute idée de progrès je
continue à penser que le progressisme a
du sens mais ça veut dire que le progrès
le progrès n'est jamais garantie ni
linéaire et que si nous ne faisons rien
progrès ou pas nous allons en effet vers
une catastrophe écologique annoncée
j'ajouterai que c'était aussi pour ne
pas me parler du coc vide dans cette
image
parce qu'on n'en parle d'abord trop à
mon avis mais surtout parce que je pense
que le réchauffement climatique est
beaucoup plus grave et fera beaucoup
plus de morts que la colline 19 mai il
peut être que les conséquences de
lakovic 19 seront bien plus grande
encore et vont s'effacer au fond notre
crainte du réchauffement climatique ne
croyez vous pas non ça je ne crois pas
du tout les conséquences économiques
vont être très lourds sont déjà très
lourdes a dit que la banque mondiale
annonce que 105
millions d'êtres humains vont retomber
en dessous du seuil de l'extrême
pauvreté 150 millions ce qu'ils
considéraient en nocture a effectivement
des milliers de morts mais ça ne remet
pas en cause
j'ai envie de dire l'existence de
l'humanité une pandémie où le taux de
mortalité est entre 0,3 et 0,5 pour cent
il n'y a aucune chance que ça examine
humanité le réchauffement climatique
peut éventuellement compromettre jusqu'à
l'existence de l'humanité sur au
bien-être de nos enfants et de nos
petits-enfants
pour moi la question écologique en
général c'est la priorité des décennies
qui viennent
est-ce que vous pouvez nous la commenter
j'ai ma petite idée mais je préfère que
ce soit vous qu'ils disaient non mais je
les ai vécus en plus je sortais l'autre
jour de la gare saint lazare et on a
descendu avec un taxi l'avenue de
l'opéra et tout d'un coup
en plus si c'était un peu le soir c'est
et glauque il y avait ces grands murs de
béton couvert de tags seiplo hideux à
moitié tordu par pour les uns tout ça au
milieu de l'avenue de l'opéra avec au
fond le palais garnier est quand même
une des plus belles images de paris
l'alignement des immeubles sis parisien
également et tout d'un coup je vous dis
mes clics ou est ce que je suis ce que
je suis à beyrouth peut-être dans une
ville en guerre civile ou alors encore
dans une ville du tiers monde on n'a
jamais fini les travaux qu'on avait
commencé et nous on était à paris au
coeur de paris de ce beau pari et je me
suis dit mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire ce qu'on peut créer comme
laideur au nom du bien
si vous voulez parce que ça c'est pour
protéger la planète et pour protéger les
cyclistes sauf qui avait pas de
cyclistes d'ailleurs comme pas plus que
sur cette photo et comment est-ce qu'on
peut quoi la vandaliser une ville au nom
d'une bonne cause
mais on pourrait élargir assez notre
époque parce qu'on pourrait vous dire ça
par exemple certains paysages recouverts
d'éoliennes par exemple comment est-ce
qu'on peut créer autant de laideur au
nom du bien et comment est-ce qu'on peut
créer donc une espèce de mal
qui est qui est parfois pire que ce
qu'on a voulu éviter
voilà c'est d'autant plus intéressant
que ce soit venue de l'opéra c'est que
vous savez la carte caractéristiques de
cette avenue
c'est la seule à paris qu'il a pas
d'arbres et pourquoi il n'y a pas
d'arbres a vu le perso j'aimerais
justement pour respecter cette
perspective dont napoléon iii était si
fier avec le avec l'opéra jusqu'au bout
voilà voilà
et effectivement maintenant il ya
beaucoup de jaune il ya toujours peu de
pâte de verre mehiaoui cette zone là il
est il est terrible c'est une une de
charlie hebdo alors je vous laisse là
commenté cédric passard oui en fait on a
choisi cette scène une parce qu'elle
révèle bien en fait les polémiques qui
est qu'ils ont créée par rapport à la
satire depuis une bonne dizaine d'années
c'est à dire que dans les années 80 on
avait évidemment des forme de satire qui
était qui étaient présentes notamment
sur un registre télévisuel mais c'est un
peu dépolitiser on pense au bébête show
on pense à ce qui existait dans les
grands formats médiatique et charlie
hebdo qui existe depuis assez longtemps
c'est vrai que symbolise bien là toutes
les détentions les crispations qui n'ont
pu ressurgir ces dernières années et
donc c'est tunnel fait référence à un
moment où justement on avait enjoint
charlie hebdo à être un journal
responsable et donc là la réponse de
charlie hebdo c'était de dire voilà on
va vous montrer ce que c'est qu'un
journal responsables les avait fait une
une blanche en fait comme si finalement
ajourné un responsable si les satiriques
saint jouin qu'on ne pouvait rien dire
et cet autre une qui était justement la
version de la satire en tant que tel qui
joue avec le feu au fond oui de miramont
ccao fawcett c'est une aurait aurait pu
être la couverture de votre livre on
al'impression elle donne une parfaite
définition
alors ils disent l'invention de l'humour
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt
l'invention de la satire justement
l'humour cet anglais oui oui
effectivement puisque là si on définit
l'humour par le fait de se moquer de
soi-même là en fait on est dans un cadre
tout à fait différent puisque en fait le
contexte qu'il faut peut-être rappeler
très vieille brièvement c'était en 2012
c'était l'époque où un une sorte de film
était sorti en vidéo s'appelle une
l'innocence des musulmans et avait
suscité quelques manifestations et même
quelques émeutes et donc charlie hebdo à
cette époque-là avait relayé
l'information publiée aussi quelques
caricatures en 2012 et le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'époque qui
était dans mon souvenir laurent fabius
avait effectivement en juin à charlie
hebdo
à de faire de faire preuve de
responsabilité effectivement il ya cette
métaphore de l'huile et du feu donc
c'est à dire bon il ne faut pas jeter
d'huile sur le feu ils semblent en fait
l'interprétation qu'on peut donner de
cette caricature c'est que la satire par
essence est presque de façon originale
consiste évidemment à jeter d'huile sur
le feu si on pouvait pas le faire y
aurait pas de ça tire et ça renvoie
effectivement une sorte d'innocence
fresque d'étape premier de ce qui serait
le geste satire et qui consiste
évidemment à se moquer et à s'affranchir
des conséquences éventuelles de ces
gestes ou des enfants tout cas ce qu'on
montre qu'ils sont elles de la
responsabilité du politique en principe
[Musique]
oui